[Music]
[Applause]
for example I was watching America's Got
Talent
was watching the show America's Got
Talent yeah and then I didn't know
what's going on so I hit the info button
and it said Rekha's Got Talent or as
it's known in China
America's Got about five years I was
watching Aqua Teen Hunger Force yeah
yeah then I hit the info button it said
if you can explain the plot you will
fail 39 state sobriety test I was
watching The Bachelorette yeah
watching The Bachelorette yeah and then
I hit the info button it said brought to
you by the letters HP
I was watching that new show ballers I
was watching the show ballers yeah yeah
then I hit the info button it said like
entourage with 20% more high five Real
Housewives of Orange County The Real
Housewives of Orange County yeah and
then I checked it out I hit the button
it said discarded flesh from a
dermatologists office is molded into
faces and hand puppeted by a team of
experts ruff
true detective I was watching true
detective yeah then I hit the info
button and it said if you love last
season you'll watch this season it's a
Dora the Explorer yeah hit the info
button Donald Trump's worst nightmare
and Hispanic immigrant with no job and
God knows what in the back
[Applause]
Oh c-span - I was watching c-span - yeah
tonight oh shut up yeah then I hit the
info button and said oh hey I think your
cat walked on the remote but Teen Mom -
watching Teen Mom 2 then I hit a button
and it said meet the girls who learn
nothing from watching -
and finally I checked out diners
drive-ins and dives and I hit the button
and it said hair found in a swimming
pool filter comes to life demands a
deep-fried hotdog
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography